Попри пов  ітряні тривоги й війну, що триває, Бородянка на Київщині повертається до життя.
На початку березня на ці дев'ятиповерхівки окупанти з літаків скинули бомби.
У підвалах залишилися заживо похованими щонайменше 26 мирних жителів.
Нині завали розібрали, вирви від бомб засипали.
А руїни на вулиці Центральній стали одним з обов'язкових пунктів для відвідування іноземними лідерами.
Утім майбутнє зруйнованих будинків під питанням.
Місцеві побоюються, що на руїнах можуть звести бізнес-центр чи ще гірше - збережуть в нинішньому вигляді як меморіал.
Катерина втратила житло в цьому розбомбленому будинку.
Вона запевняє, що пам'ятає про загиблих сусідів і без меморіалу,
а сама хоче жити у відновленому на тому ж місці будинку.
Спочатку було тяжко, дуже тяжко, але що робити, якщо це війна і ніхто від цього не застрахований.
Тяжко? Так. Але далі треба жити і не дивитися на це все.
Олена живе на сусідній вулиці. Їй так само складно бачити зі свого вікна згарище.
Я хочу тільки на фотографіях це бачити, і щоб мої внуки, правнуки це все бачили на фотографіях.
Хоча внучка теж сюди приїхала і каже: "Мамо, я не хочу сюди ходити, тут дуже страшно".
У Державному агентстві розвитку туризму вже замислилися над тим,
як Україна зберігатиме пам'ять про події 2022 року. Хоча й визнають, що тема чутлива.
Десь забути, перегорнути - це є дуже така травматична пам'ять.
Дуже часто травматичні моменти ми забуваємо - це така специфіка людської психології,
важливо це запам'ятати для того, щоб не повторити.
З одного боку, мають бути ці місця, куди люди можуть прийти порефлексувати,
зокрема, про свою втрату, про свій біль, свій героїзм.
З іншого боку, це не має бути щоденне для них нагадування.
В агентстві розпочали обговорення з урядом, як створювати пам'ятні місця.
Обіцяють насамперед орієнтуватися на думку громадськості,
відмовитися від радянського возвеличення війни і залучати іноземних фахівців.
Це точно не мають залишитися просто зруйновані, згорілі будинки.
Ми маємо ряд таких меморіалів, і це наприклад 11 вересня в Нью-Йорку - "близнюки",
які були зруйновані, в яких загинули дуже багато людей, там створений певний меморіал.
Цей будинок в Бородянці, на мою думку особисту, він має отримати символічне таке представлення в подальшому,
але не бути просто згорілим будинком, який буде травмувати мешканців міста.
Зберігати свідчення злочинів росіян у цифровому вигляді пропонують автори проєкту "Війна впритул".
Вони відзняли з дронів і 3D-камер наслідки обстрілів і бойових дій на Київщині, Чернігівщині, Сумщині
й створили віртуальний музей. Орієнтувалися на іноземну аудиторію.
Навіть на мобільному телефоні ви можете побачити - ось це Бородянка.
Ви навіть оком своїм не можете так детально, довго стояти і бути на цій висоті, на місці зруйнованої квартири.
Ось ми зараз тут стоїмо. Ми дивимося вниз, бачимо, як валяються дитячі іграшки, меблі якісь.
Тобто склалися 10 поверхів.
За словами Юрія Зозулі, зйомками з 3D-камер уже зацікавилися розробників відеоігор.
Хочуть доповнити шутери, тобто "стрілялки", локаціями з України.
Автори проєкту "Війна впритул" також планують розмістити свої зображення на сервісі Google Street View,
а потім додати й зйомки відбудови.
І в такий спосіб увіковічнити історію.
Це найголовніша всенародна фіксація злочину.
Мало того - ми своїми 3D-камерами проникли у всі квартири, у всі танки, у всю бронетехніку.
Тобто це пам'ять на всі покоління - цифрова пам'ять, а вона - найнадійніша.
Тому що міста можуть змінюватися, там відбудували, а це залишиться навіки.
Волонтер і голова Асоціації чорнобильських туроператорів Ярослав Ємельяненко
працює над тим, аби зберегти наочні свідчення окупації Зони відчуження.
Буквально, коли ми їздили по чорнобильському та причорнобильському регіону на другий день після деокупації,
там була абсолютно одна картина - стояли танки, міни, розумієте, розбиті хати.
Я приїхав туди за кілька тижнів - розпустилася трава, люди розтягли і техніку, і рештки перебування окупантів.
Тобто здогадатися, що там щось відбувалося, було вже неможливо.
Ярослав Ємельяненко порівнює збереження пам'яті про нинішні події з Чорнобильською трагедією.
І наполягає на тому, що побачене на власні очі вражає людей значно більше.
Всі ось ці докази треба коректно на окремі майданчики вивозити,
щоб кожен район міг показати, що відбувалося тут, розповісти свої історії.
Тому що коли ти показуєш просто фотографії, до людей це не так доходить,
ніж коли вони самі можуть побачити, наприклад, ось таку техніку.
Бо коли ми розповідали в Чорнобильській зоні про процес ліквідації наслідків аварії,
скільки тисяч, сотень тисяч ліквідаторів тут працювали, скільки техніки, сотень тисяч одиниць їздило, вони про це слухали.
Але розуміли вони це тільки коли потрапляли на відстійник ліквідаторської техніки "Розсоха",
де стояло півтори тисячі одиниць броньованої радянської техніки.
Ідеться насамперед про спалену техніку, військові "трофеї".
Такі "виставки" вже можна побачити в Києві. Зокрема, на Михайлівській площі.
Першою була експозиція біля Національного військово-історичного музею.
Його співробітник - історик Євгеній Шупік - сам долучився до збору експонатів на Київщині.
Серед них рідкісна техніка окупантів. Наприклад, бронетранспортер "Ракушка".
Вартість однієї одиниці цієї техніки на 2019 рік становила близько 900 тисяч доларів.
І росіяни вважали, що це універсальний "аналоговнєтний" бронетранспортер, він авіадесантований, плаваючий.
І от ця техніка. Як ви бачите, "покатушки на ракушке" в Україні для російських десантників часто завершувалися фатально, так само і тут.
Ця експозиція, за словами Євгенія, тимчасова - стоятиме до перемоги України.
Потім відберуть лише зразки, які можуть мати історичну цінність і залишать їх у філіях музею по Україні.
Поки ж виставка користується популярністю.
По-перше, дітям завжди подобається техніка.
По-друге, можливість доторкнутися до війни.
Справа в тім, що більшість людей, які пережили цей місяць у Києві, не бачили поля бою, не відчували цього, вони лише дивилися новини.
Це не те, до чого хочеться торкатися, але це те, чим живе країна і зараз сказати,
що люди можуть жити поза цим, не звертаючи уваги на це, напевно, важко.
І скоріше це демонстрація спроможності українських захисників ефективно нищити ворожу техніку,
спроможність відстояти Київ, спроможність перемогти.
"Експозиції" ворожої техніки на Київщині можна зустріти повсюди.
На одній із таких, неподалік Бучі, ми вже зустріли першого туриста.
Дайсуке Тарутані - юрист і волонтер з японського міста Кобе.
Його дружина - українка. Тож чоловік приїхав, аби підтримати Україну й побачити все на власні очі.
Я побачив факти, правду. Тому що багато ЗМІ у новинах часто не говорять правду.
Насправді ми бачимо, що ситуація ось яка. Це війна!
Жахлива, страшна. Я бачив багато зруйнованих будинків тут, сліди від бомб…
Спалена техніка Дайсуке теж вразила. Він переконаний, що її варто розмістити в музеях.
На мою думку, це місце - як нагадування, щоб люди могли пам'ятати.
Адже ось це знищили українці. Це важливо пам'ятати.
П'ятий поверх, он наша квартира. Чорні двері відкриті.
У Бородянці Людмила з чоловіком Олександром і донькою Катериною вкотре прийшли подивитися на рештки своєї квартири.
Нині родина живе в тимчасовому модульному містечку, але хоче якомога швидше повернутися до нормального життя.
У кожній квартирі були сім'ї з дітками. Їм потрібно житло. І відбудовувати - хай не на цьому місці.
Ви бачите, тут велика територія, тут є варіанти, як побудувати, але певним чином, що тут.
І ці самі сусіди, на цьому самому ж місці. Ми хочемо цього, дайте нам забути цей жах.
Такої думки усі жителі зруйнованого будинку.
Поки держава думає, що робити зі згарищем, на фасаді з'являються плакати
з вимогами швидше будувати нове житло на цьому ж місці.
А на сходах - "стихійний" меморіал - свічки у пам'ять про загиблих жителів.